- [Instructor] Hess's law
states that the overall change
in enthalpy for a chemical
reaction is equal to the sum
of the enthalpy changes for each step.
And this is independent of the path taken.
So it doesn't matter what
set of reactions you use.
If you add up those reactions
and they equal the reaction
that you're trying to find,
you can also sum the enthalpies
to find the enthalpy
change for the reaction.
As an example, let's say we're
trying to find the change
in enthalpy for the reaction
of carbon with hydrogen gas
to form C2H2, which is acetylene.
We can calculate the change
in enthalpy for the formation
of acetylene using these
three reactions below.
Our approach will involve
looking at these three reactions
and comparing them to
the original reaction
to see if we need to change anything.
For example, if we look at reaction one,
there's one mole of acetylene
on the left side of the equation.
And if we compare that
to the original reaction,
there's one mole of
acetylene on the right side
of the equation.
So we need to reverse equation one
to make it look more like
our original reaction.
To save time, I've gone ahead
and reversed equation one.
So you can see, I did that down here.
Looking at the original
equation for equation one,
here where the products
and now we've made those
products the reactants.
And what were the reactants
over here for equation one
have now become the products.
The change in enthalpy for equation one
is -1,299.6 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
Kilojoules per mole reaction
just means how the reaction
is written in the balanced equation.
And since we reversed equation one,
we also need to reverse
the sign for Delta H.
So instead of this being a negative,
instead of this being a negative,
we're gonna go ahead and
change this into a positive.
And also let's go ahead and
cross out the first equation.
So we don't get confused.
Next, we look at equation two
and we compare it to our original.
For equation two there's
one mole of solid carbon
on the left side and looking
at our original reaction,
there's two moles of
carbon on the left side.
So to get equation two, to
look like our original equation
we need to multiply everything
through, by a factor of two.
So we're gonna multiply
everything in equation two
by a factor of two.
To save some time, I have
gone ahead and written out
what we would get.
We would get two carbons plus two O2s
goes to 2CO2.
The change in the
enthalpy for the formation
of one mole of CO2
was -393.5 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
But now we're forming two moles of CO2.
And since we multiplied
the equation through
by a factor of two, we also need
to multiply the change in enthalpy
by a factor of two as well.
And also let's go ahead and cross out
this first version here
because now we're
forming two moles of CO2.
Next, we look at equation three
and we can see there's
one mole of hydrogen gas
on the left side of the equation
which matches the original reaction
which also has one mole of
hydrogen gas on the left side.
So we don't need to do
anything to equation three.
And since we're not doing
anything to the equation,
we're also not gonna do anything
to the change in the enthalpy.
So it's gonna stay -285.8
kilojoules per mole of reaction.
Next we add up all of our
reactants and products.
So we have two CO2 plus
H2O plus 2C plus 2O2
plus H2 plus one half O2.
So those are all written
down here for our reactants.
And then for the products, let
me just change colors here.
We have C2H2 plus 5O2
plus 2CO2 plus H2O.
And so those are written
over here for the products.
Next we see what we can cancel out.
There's 2CO2 on the left side
and there's 2CO2 on the right side.
So those cancel out.
There's one water on the left
and one water on the right.
And there's 2O2s plus one half O2
which is 2.5O2s or five halves O2s.
So the oxygen's cancel
out on both sides as well.
And we can see we're left with
two carbons plus one hydrogen
goes to form one C2H2
which is the same as
our original equation.
Since we were able to add up our equations
and get the overall equation,
according to Hess's law,
we should also be able to
add the changes in enthalpies
for these steps to get
the change in the enthalpy
for the overall reaction.
If we look at the changes in enthalpy
for the individual steps, we had +1299.6
for the first equation.
And so that's up here.
For the second equation we
had negative 393.5 times two,
which is -787.
And for our third equation, we had -285.8.
So that's -285.8.
When we add everything together
we get +226.8 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
So for the formation of
one mole of acetylene
from two moles of carbon
and one mole of hydrogen
the change in enthalpy for this reaction
is equal to +226.8 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.